don't come any closer I'll jump
everyone listen time here from Paris
games week we're here to talk about
Detroit become human so we saw behind
closed doors demo kind of a branch in
version of the trailer that was shown at
the Sony press conference time what do
you think I really I'm struggling to
process my emotions regarding this game
it's a weird one because you can't
outright say yeah the domestic one yeah
it's great it's fantastic violence but
like it's it was yeah it was difficult
to watch and at the same time what's
tricky about is like you have to play at
this point a previous age you have to
kind of decide whether you want to play
some faith in the team who are making
the game to provide an experience I'll
deal with that issue with sensitivity in
the rest of the game so we've seen a
very limited slice of the game with
little to no contact contacts yeah and
which is incredibly important you know
in isolation that that was very
difficult to watch during a stream the
original announced and also in the
second viewing we had of it there's
things about it there are troublesome to
watch like I wouldn't I think
troublesome is a weird word because it
kind of it troublesome appears like
you're saying it's problematic
yeah I mean we actually did talk to
David that cage about this and he was
saying things like you know it's it's a
collaboration storytelling between
especially in video games between the
creators and the audience and it kind of
feels like if you don't tackle subjects
like this yeah then can't wear the video
games go through this is that is their
cut off about things that video games
caning you cannot talk about so I for
one I'm quite very interested and
intrigued by
there seen that particularly the one
that they chose to show at Paris games
week they said that it was particularly
I seen because it was it could be
standalone yeah and of course it did
have a hot heavy emotional in yeah so
like troublesome I use that phrases
because for myself it was difficult to
figure out what I how I feel about it
and what we came to was we have to place
that trust in David cage and his team to
create the context that we were lacking
in this moment outside of it that will
make that that one scene makes sense and
have value beyond shock value and again
like in the moment that stuff that we
saw was powerful and it was difficult to
were uncomfortable and that's kind of
the point right and like it deals with
human emotions and like someone that's
non-human and the way you and the whole
point of the story is androids trying to
gain some sort of humanity and become
their own you know you know people
almost and you do that by experience
these powerful emotions and one of those
powerful emotions is empathy and dread
and horror and feeling powerless and
that kind of stuff so in that respect it
did its job and it did it well I felt
angry I felt sad I felt bad for the you
know the kid I hated Todd in that moment
yeah so like it clearly has the
potential to affect which is I guess
what we want out of it and like I said
I've said a bunch of times we just got a
hope that they are capable and have the
expertise to provide the necessary
context and make that stuff matter
context context is everything
but we also played you played
specifically dude I played so the
hostage negotiation which I think was
from III but it was my first time
actually getting hands on with Detroit
and I felt like so when we were watching
a hand the scene behind closed doors of
the Cara Todd Alice scene there's
obviously a lot more going on because
it's you know stuff I'd seen your
quickly reacting to things whereas the
serious thing was quite sedate you were
doing an investigation you
you know you're trying to save a child
who was being held hostage by an Android
was feeling very emotional it was a lot
of tensions running high and so it was
nice to have the kind of experience
those two different sides of the story
it's the exciting the sightings of
difficult word to use but you know the
high octane yeah part as well as the
slow methodical there was also kind of
like a you know Batman Arkham origins
the yeah the crime scenes piecing
together which is really cool and also
just the way that you could stack the
odds in your favor the thing obviously
was Detroit as with all quantitating
games there's many options different
ways that things can play out and what
was cool is they they showed you in
multiple ways that things could play out
there were a lot of branches that were
locked as well so you can clearly
encourages you to go back and replay it
kind of gives you a full flow chart of
all the things that can happen and by
having things locked you can kind of
like reverse engineer it to deduce how
you'd get to that thing people to say
whether what kind of what degree they
are different from each other it could
be like my new differences but who knows
I can't stand that noise anymore
gentlemen helicopter to get out of here
so yeah I'm hesitant to say that I'm
excited about it yes given you know it
requires us
it requires the actual broader game
external world game to be treated with
some sensitivity and kind of like make
all the harrowing things that happen in
that game have meaning and until that
happens like I can't like just be like
yeah yeah but I'm glad that someone's
trying it and trying to tackle this
these are issues I'm not surprised that
it's getting some backlash but movies
have done it literature has done it TV
shows have done it it's it makes sense
for games to do it I think the tricky
thing is it's a blockbuster game that's
doing it which is why it's earning a lot
more kind of like attention if it was an
early game it would being less of a deal
if it was an indie game it would be
lauded for tackling these things but
because it's triple-a there seems to be
some pushback but I would love to be
able to say you know spring 2018 when we
played the whole game yeah that Detroit
does what its setting it yeah also like
it is people are obviously giving some
backlash to it because it is david cage
and Quantic Dream's and some people have
their opinion everyone has their
opinions on them some people love them
some people think they're not as right
some of these words they have plot holes
so there's some hesitancy because of
that stuff and that is understand I'm on
that side I also have that concern but
for now we're just gonna have to hope
that they're able to do it justice all
right well for more on Detroit Ming che
keep your eyes peeled to gamespot.com
video games legitimate art